it is the season of giving to help
brighten up the holidays for local
families who are struggling we're
hosting the great toy drive we've
partnered with tobin dealerships and
telus international to collect donations
for shade tree we have hector mejia live
this afternoon at tobin kia down in
henderson where they're taking donations
right now hi hector
that's correct taylor john we are taking
donations and these are some of the
items that have been dropped off here at
tobin kia here in henderson so every one
of these whether it's a doll a barbie a
car even a football they will all go to
the shade tree a shelter for victims of
domestic violence mainly women and
children you know a small gift can
really help a family get through the
holidays this season and here's how you
can help at home the great toy drive
runs now through wednesday december 15th
you can bring a new unwrapped toy or a
gift card to the locations you see on
your screen that includes tobin auto
group dealerships we also partnered with
telus international which is a company
located by decatur and sahara we have
the information for the locations listed
right now on eightnewsnow.com and back
out here live look at this paw patrol we
have a football here in the remote
control car if you can help us help
families this is just one way and again
we have everything listed on
eightnessnow.com there was a llama
reporting live hector mejia live local
now back to you